I'm Bianca Currington.
I am in America on an exchange program with Virgin America.
Virgin Blue, Virgin America have swapped crew for one year,...
...to experience each other's culture and differences in work.
I'm Sarah.
I'm 26 years old.
I am from Western Australia, a place called Perth.
Virgin America is such a great company to work for.
They are so young, they're so fresh, they're so vibrant,...
...and they make you want to support them in every single way,...
...because you work in such a vibrant atmosphere,...
...you can't help be that person as well.
It's a fantastic opportunity to be able to live somewhere else for a year,...
...and enjoy that time and see how the other Virgin brands work.